I want to start first with your thoughts
on Tom Brady we were just watching the
press conference that he gave there were
reporters were really hammering him with
questions like he's Tom Brady a cheater
what did you think of his reaction how
his face looked how would you assess it
this was not a successful press
conference I've gone through the last
two seasons and facially coated a lot of
Tom Brady press conferences in this case
the anxiety level is probably four to
five times higher than normal and no
wonder what he said I have no knowledge
of the situation as if he couldn't talk
to Belichick it reminds me a lot of a
wonderful Saturday now Saturday and I've
skid actually a second city skit where
John Belushi is playing Sam Erwin says
what I want to know is what did the
president know and when did he stop
knowing it that's kind of how this press
conference struck me I saw the fear I
saw a lot of sadness because I think he
realizes this is gonna tarnish his image
going forward and a fair amount of
disgusting contempt and I've seen that
in liars and I don't know these lying
per se I don't know his knowledge but
you're in a situation where someone
around you did something and you're
showing contempt it shows that you're
just come to relieve I mean to a certain
extent Dan I mean if he had sat up there
and you know he kind of smiled and
treated this you know kind of
nonchalantly then we'd be sitting here
saying gosh you know Tom Brady doesn't
understand the seriousness of these
accusations and that was Monday Monday
when he kind of laughed it off a bit
more today was anxiety was a lot of
sadness on his face quite honestly
probably six seven times more than I see
if he loses the game reputation to a
certain extent I mean given how this
story has just exploded he needed to
show that kind of sensitivity to this it
was a gravitas it was a you know
understanding that this is a big deal I
would agree with you but I think the
answers you know really don't take you
toward it and a solution and trying to
investigate to get to an outcome and he
was obviously quite familiar with you
know what kind of ball he liked to play
in terms of the
nation level so I would agree with you
that he's taken on the gravitas but the
amount of discomfort he had almost a bit
of a emotional distancing from his own
answers so I'm certainly not here to say
that he was responsible in any fashion
but he really was profoundly kind of
emotionally removing himself with
disgust and contempt from answers and in
a situation that clearly he doesn't
welcome a different kind of Tom Brady
than what you have seen before